A long time ago, I
had a bear cub that I took care of like a younger
brother.It's been a year, so I tried to let the cub escape before it was beautiful
.
After all, it's
a way of thinking that kills or kills repeatedly rather than killing
.  The posture of animals is an important deity for us.In
the land of the gods, animals are in human form and come to our world to play with their animal skins and meat.Among them, the
highest rank is the bear Kim.  It
's an honor to raise that bear cub It
will be raised with care for
a year When you send the time demon you bought, the whole village will hold a grand ceremony
This beauty is called Iomante
This world of ours  Have other gods tell you that it's a fun place
Then the kamuy will visit again and again Pasiripa believes that
Faith contains the way we live
For example, a bear cub we caught  I think the reason we raise them is because the more they grow, the more fur and meat we can get.
I keep a distance so that I don't see it in my
mind.It's a
realistic way of thinking.As I thought, I
'm a little strange among the Ainu, isn't it?
I'm an Ainu woman of the times